aquí tenemos un sistema interesante
tenemos dos compartimientos en el
compartimiento izquierdo tenemos un gas
que tiene una temperatura de de sur
y del lado derecho tenemos un gas que
esta temperatura te sube y están
separados por una pared con profundidad
de y el área de contacto de la pared y
el gas es
y suponemos que estos gases están
completamente separados de lo que tengo
curiosidad suponiendo que el gas rosa
tiene una temperatura más alta que el
gas azul y debido a esto vamos a tener
una transferencia de energía térmica de
izquierda a derecha a la energía térmica
que se transfiere le llamamos calor y la
denotamos con la letra q mayúscula tengo
curiosidad por saber cuál es la tasa de
la transferencia de calor cuánto calor
es transferido por unidad de tiempo a
esto se refiere la tasa de transferencia
y quiero saber cómo cambia esto
dependiendo de cómo cambien estas
diferentes variables por ejemplo si
nuestra área de contacto a aumentar a
qué pasaría con q sobre t pues q sobre t
también aumentaría por unidad de tiempo
ya que tendría mayor área para que las
moléculas de este gas caliente golpeen y
caliente en esta pared habrá más calor
en el muro para calentar el gas azul
por lo que en este caso la tasa o razón
de la transferencia de calor por el
tiempo también va a aumentar
pero si hago más pequeña en mi
superficie de contacto
también disminuirá mi razón de
transferencia de calor
esto suena congruente con el sentido
común
qué pasa con el grosor del muro si lo
hago más grueso que le pasará a la tasa
de transferencia de calor en este caso
tendré más cosas que calentar antes de
que se pueda comenzar a calentar el gas
de la derecha obviamente este es un
proceso continuo que sucede
constantemente pero habrá más material
que calentar por lo que tardará más
tiempo y más de esta energía cinética
promedio se va a disipar en esta pared
por lo que si esta pared se hace más
gruesa la tasa de transferencia de calor
va a disminuir o si la pared se vuelve
más delgada entonces la tasa de
transferencia de calor va a aumentar la
tasa de transferencia de calor es
inversamente proporcional al grosor de
esta pared
qué más podríamos hacer
podemos pensar en la diferencia de
temperatura está diferencia este sub a
menos te sube si esta diferencia de
temperatura aumentará qué va a pasar el
sentido común nos dice que si esto está
súper caliente mucho más caliente que lo
que tenemos a la derecha tendremos una
mayor transferencia de calor la tasa de
transferencia de calor por unidad de
tiempo va a aumentar y de la misma
manera si esta diferencia de temperatura
disminuyera no se podríamos pensar el
caso extremo de que no hubiera
diferencia de temperatura no tendríamos
ninguna transferencia de calor por lo
que tiene sentido que al disminuir la
diferencia de temperatura también va a
disminuir la tasa de transferencia de
calor va a ser proporcional a la
diferencia de temperatura
como podríamos encapsular todo este
conocimiento en una sola fórmula que
describa la conductividad térmica qué
tan rápido puede ocurrir la
transferencia de calor podemos decir que
la tasa de transferencia de calor y esto
viene de cierta intuición de lo que
hicimos aquí podemos decir que es
proporcional a qué cosas de aquí pues
mientras más áreas de contacto tengamos
en la pared mayor será la transferencia
de calor así que es proporcional al área
de contacto también es proporcional a la
diferencia de temperatura multiplicamos
por la diferencia de temperatura de a
menos tv
y es inversamente proporcional al grosor
de la pared
esto entre el grosor de la pared
otra cosa que podríamos decir es esta
constante de proporcionalidad
será esto diferente para distintos
materiales si esto fuera una pared de
metal conduciría el calor más rápido en
comparación de una pared de madera así
que está acá es dependiente del material
de la pared
ustedes pueden medir esto para
diferentes materiales materiales
diferentes tendrán conductividad es
térmicas diferentes que es esta variable
de aquí con algo de intuición llegamos a
lo que parece una fórmula sofisticada se
encontrarán esta fórmula para calcular
la conductividad térmica a través de una
barrera sólida pero ya vieron que esto
lo deducimos usando el sentido común la
transferencia de calor por unidad de
tiempo es proporcional a la constante de
proporcionalidad del material el unicel
tiene una menor constante y por eso
servimos bebidas calientes en vasos de
unicel
va a ser proporcional al área de
contacto y a la diferencia de
temperatura e inversamente proporcional
al grosor del muro si queremos aislar
algo tenemos que minimizar esta área y
maximizar el grosor del muro y usar un
material con una baja constante de
conductividad algo hecho de unicel con
forma esférica sería muy bueno para
aislar la temperatura